ALI AFSHAR: Everyone, my name
is Ali, and this is Ivan.
And today we're going to be
talking to you about the
Google Drive API, the new
Google Drive API.
It was launched at I/O, and
we're going to take you right
down under the water to see all
the beautiful things we
can find in this API.
So this year we launched
Google Drive.
Very proud of that.
And with Google Drive, which is
our cloud storage solution,
allows you to store files in
a safe place, allows you to
access them anywhere, and
brings to you the
collaborative features of Google
Docs, so you can use
them on your files
in Google Drive.
And with that, we launched
the Google Drive SDK.
This SDK allows you to put your
application in front of
all of our users.
So if they like your
application, they can install
it, they can use it
in Google Drive.
And that very much enhances our
product, but at the same
time allows you to put
your product in front
of all these people.
The other part of this is we've
tried to make this API
as easy to use as possible, as
effortless to use as possible.
So you get all the features of
Google Drive, but you get them
programmatically, and you can
use them in your applications.
So what is the API?
How does the API relate
to the SDK?
The API is part of the SDK that
is responsible for making
programmatic calls against
Google Drive.
The other bits are little user
interface snippets and that
kind of thing.
You may have heard of them in
the other talks we've had.
So programmatically manage
a user's Google Drive.
Whatever you can do with Google
Drive, you can do with
the Google Drive API.
We're going to talk a
few of those things.
Well, the first one is
uploading files.
That's the main use case.
Of course, you have
to get your files
somehow into Google Drive.
We allow you to organize your
files into folders.
Again, you can do that in Drive,
but you can do that
programmatically
using the API.
You can search for files.
All the powerful search features
of Google Drive come
to you from the API.
Once your files are
in, you should be
able to download them.
We give you a list of changes.
That means a sequential list
of all the things that have
changed in a user's
Google Drive.
There is a revision history.
So much like a version control
system, we allow you to manage
these revisions
programmatically.
There is full sharing support.
One of our favorite features,
sharing and collaboration.
You can perform all of this
sharing programmatically on
behalf of a user.
We have some user information
bits that we think that's very
useful for applications that
want to personalize
themselves.
For example, displaying an image
of the user in the top
right hand corner, or displaying
their email
address, just so the user
knows exactly that your
application knows
who they are.
And then we've got these two
really cool features of
processing files when
you upload them.
And they are OCR and
translation.
Now, OCR is optical character
recognition--
I'm sure you all know--
and that allows us to extract
text from non-textual files.
So if you have a PDF, you have
an image that has textual
content, that can be extracted
by the API when you upload or
update files.
Similarly, translation.
That's human language
translation.
If you have a document in French
and you'd like it to
appear in your drive translated
into English or any
other language, you specify the
query parameters and that
happens there.
So you can see here that this
is a very large feature set
for an API.
There's a lot of,
lot of things.
Important for me to tell you now
is that your integrations
with the API can be small
integrations--
you can just have a
bit of sharing--
or they can be large
integrations--
you can have uploads, downloads,
file management.
It really depends on your
type of application.
Some applications are more
suited than others.
But really, any application
that involves
files of some kind.
They don't even have
to be actual files.
Something that looks like a file
is a good fit to have a
Google Drive API integration.
Some of you have used the
Documents List API--
one of the three previous
versions.
And really, the Drive API
aims to replace the
Documents List API.
It should provide all
the functionality.
The point about this is the
Documents List API is
something that's been around
for a long time, and it's a
mature, well-tested
piece of software.
A lot of people use it.
So we've really taken this
infrastructure, and we've
upgraded it.
We tried to make it
easier to use.
And part of that is by using the
latest and greatest Google
API technologies which gives
you really good client
libraries, which gives
you really excellent
documentation.
And the final thing we've done
is we've tried to improve some
of the things we didn't
really like about the
Documents List API.
And one of them is the security
scoping model, which
I'll talk about now.
In the Documents List API, the
user used to have to grant
access to their complete
drive.
So you couldn't just say, I
want this application to
access just this type of file
or just these few files.
You'd have to give access
to everything.
Now that can be a bit
of a nightmare.
Users traditionally don't really
read those warnings
when they say they're about
to access the whole drive.
But people who do
care are domain
administrators, for example.
You don't want corporate
documents to be in the hand of
third party applications
if you can help it.
You can have private
applications and private
documents in your drive-- for
example, tax returns, that
kind of thing-- that you don't
want people to have.
And so for that reason, we've
added different scoping levels
to try and improve this.
Of course, we still provide the
full scope, which allows
an application to have full
access to your drive.
This is very useful for
some use cases.
For example, if you want to
back up an entire user's
drive, you need that.
But we've added these
other scopes.
Two read-only scopes, one which
allows downloading and
one which doesn't allow
downloading.
And then what we call the per
app per file scope that is
very unique to this API.
This scope allows an application
to access only
files that have been
specifically and explicitly
allowed by the user.
So if a user says, I want your
application to access just
this file, your application will
access it, but will not
be able to access other files.
And we think this is very,
very unique and a great
feature, because it means you
don't have to provide access
to your whole drive.
And lastly, we have the
anonymous scope, and that is
the scope you get given
if you're not a
logged-in user at the time.
Useful for things like
public sharing.
What is the API itself?
Well, it's a standard
web-based API.
We use JSON, we use HTTPS, and
OAuth 2.0 is the recommended
authorization method.
What does that mean?
Well, really it means you can
use almost whatever you like
to access the API.
Any programming language that
can make HTTPS calls, any
programming language that can
pass JSON, you can use.
But of course, we would
recommend you use one of our
client libraries, and we have
a number, and they're there.
There are others as well.
If your favorite language isn't
on there, I recommend
you write your own API client
and get back to us, because
it's really much more fun than
making direct HTTP calls.
So what is the data model?
Well, Google Drive obviously
is based around files.
And when I say it's based around
files, everything in
Google Drive is a file.
We've already spoken
about folders.
But, in fact, folders
are files too.
How does that work?
Well, folders have a specific
MIME type, and that's the MIME
type we look at to see is
this a file or a folder.
This is really nice--
we think this is really nice--
because it allows you to write
one code path to handle
files and folders.
Because they're mostly
the same thing.
They have titles.
They have descriptions.
And we'll see exactly
how they look.
But it means you don't really
have to special case folders,
which we think is
really useful.
So what is in a file?
Well, a file has
two components.
All files have metadata.
Now, the metadata for a file
involves its title, its
description, the MIME
type, those kind of
things that are tagged.
And we'll see how that looks.
Some files have binary data.
Now the astute people in the
audience will know an example
of a file that has no binary
data, and that is
a folder, of course.
Folders don't have any binary
data associated with them.
But most files do.
So you have an image, it has
the title, the description,
those kind of things.
And then there's
the binary data
associated with that image.
Other kinds of file that don't
have binary data, of course,
are the Google Docs types of
files that are actually more
like a shortcut.
This entire hierarchy is built
up into the top level folder,
which we call the root folder.
And that has an alias
that you can access.
But again, that is just
a file as well.
It's slightly special,
but it's just a file.
So you have drive, root folder,
folders amongst that,
and then files underneath
those.
What does a file actually
look like?
Well, this is the representation
that comes back
to you when you make
API calls.
And I just want to point out
a couple of fields here.
The first one is the ID.
That is a consistent ID that
will be the ID of that file
for the lifetime of that file.
So you can store that in your
database, and you can use it
to fetch the file
at a later date.
Other important things.
There is the title, the
MIME type as I said.
If you look there, that
is the MIME type for
a spreadsheet file.
And there are other things,
labels, which are Boolean
attributes, for example,
trashed or hidden.
And then there's some dates--
which can be useful--
some links, some permission
information,
and other stuff there.
I've snipped out quite
a bit of stuff.
But if you've used any JSON API,
this is the kind of thing
you can expect.
The important one, the ID.
Remember, you can store that
and use it at a later date.
So great, you've seen
a bunch of JSON.
But why does it matter to you?
Well, we've thought
of a use case.
As I've said before, you can
use this API a lot in your
application, or you can use
it a little bit in your
application.
And we wanted an application
that used it a lot.
And if you can imagine a photo
album application.
So you have a bunch of photos,
and you want to store them in
your Google Drive, and you want
an application to be able
to manage these.
Conveniently, the feature set
that's required by this
application is the exact
feature set that
Google Drive has.
You want to upload the images,
you want to download them, you
want to organize them, you want
to be able to search for
them, you want to be
able to share them.
And we're going to go through
each of these in detail, and
Ivan's going to show
you how to do them.
But before we start,
Ivan, I just want
to ask you a question.
Why do spicy peppers like
uploads so much?
IVAN LEE: I have no idea.
ALI AFSHAR: No idea?
You want to try?
IVAN LEE: Completely blank.
ALI AFSHAR: Really?
Nothing?
So they can get jalapeno
drive.
No?
IVAN LEE: I don't get it.
Sorry.
ALI AFSHAR: Hell up
in your drive?
Jalapeno--
IVAN LEE: I--
ALI AFSHAR: Tough crowd.
Let's talk about uploads.
There are three types
of ways of uploading
files to Google Drive.
We provide these three different
mechanisms for
different use cases.
Fortunately, the client
libraries handle all of it for
you, all of the logic for you.
So really, it's just a
matter of specifying
which type you want.
But it's worth knowing what they
are and how they work, so
you can choose the appropriate
one for yourself.
Every time you upload a file
to Google Drive, you can
specify what kind of
processing you
would like on it.
And I've mentioned OCR.
You just add these parameters,
and your file will be OCR'd.
Again, converting
to Google Docs.
Now people who have used the
Documents List API know that
this is a place where
we've moved away.
The previous default for
Documents List API was
convert=true.
Now we don't convert
files unless you
explicitly ask us to do.
And the third one is
translation, which I've mentioned.
So adding these parameters
would translate a French
document to an English
document.
The next bit of processing we
do always on files that are
uploaded that they can be is
Google Goggles Integration.
Now those of you who have used
Google Goggles know that it's
pretty amazing.
I love it because it's something
I always show my
family, and they get to realize
how amazing Google is.
Here's an example.
This is actually a photo that
Ivan took while he was on a--
working holiday?
Working holiday?
Working holiday in Australia.
We'll call it that.
Now, he took that photo.
Now, when that's uploaded to
Google Drive you may recognize
it, this rock formation.
When that's uploaded to Google
Drive, that is indexed by the
Google Goggles back-end, and
we know what that is.
So if you search Google Drive--
and again, if you
search using the API--
searching for any of these three
terms, whether it be
Three Sisters, Katoomba, or
Australia, will show this
image in the search results.
Now, we think that's pretty
cool because there's no
metadata, there's no file name,
it doesn't use that.
It actually uses the
image itself.
And this is a feature you get
for free with the Drive API.
So back to uploads.
The first type is the
simple upload.
Now, a simple upload is where
you would just want to upload
a single file.
And you see there are
some limits there.
The first one is you have a
two megabyte size limit.
Now, that's pretty good for
small files, but there aren't
really any images these days
that you take with your camera
that can fit in two megabytes.
The other limitation is that
you can't specify metadata.
Why is it simple?
Well, it's just a post request
with the correct content type,
and you send the binary data.
The differentiator here
is you setting
the upload type parameter.
And when the upload type
parameter is set to media,
then we know that that's
a simple upload.
And you'll see this upload
type parameter is how the
client libraries choose
how to do the upload.
So you get a 201 Created
response, and an echo of the
data you sent.
So that's fine if you don't need
metadata, and you have
files less than two megabytes.
If you have bigger files, you
can use the multipart upload.
Now that is a MIME multipart
request, this time with the
upload type set to multipart.
And you send, in the first part
of the multipart, you
send the JSON--
in this case, title, "Funny
Photo." That's the metadata,
you can put any metadata
you want.
And in the second part, you
send the binary data.
So this is great.
The file size limit is 10
gigabytes, so you can really
send as much as you like
there, and whatever
metadata you want.
There is one major problem here,
and that is what do we
do in the case of failure?
We don't expect our
API to fail.
We obviously don't expect
your excellent
applications to fail.
But what could fail is the
network connection.
So if you're uploading--
not even a 10 gigabyte file.
Say you're uploading a 1
gigabyte file, and three
quarters of the way
through it, the
network connection dies.
Really, you have to
upload that again.
And for that reason, we provide
the next mechanism,
the third, which is the
resumable upload mechanism.
So how does that work?
Well, this is based
around a session.
You will have a minimum
of two requests.
The first request kicks
it all off.
So you initiate that, and
you send the metadata.
Once you've sent the metadata,
you get a response back which
contains a URL for which we
expect you to send the
remainder of the data.
And once you've sent the
remainder of the data, then
you get your 201 response
back, and that's that.
You may think, well, what's
the point in that?
I've just done two requests
when I could have done one
with the multipart.
Well, the beauty of it is, in
a situation of failure, when
the network dies, you can ask
the API, how much have I
already uploaded?
Exactly how many bytes
have I uploaded?
And when you make that request,
if it's not a
completed file, you get a 308
Resume Incomplete response,
which contains information
on where to restart.
So you can restart the upload
only from where you left off,
and you upload the remainder
of the file.
What does it look like
in HTTP terms?
Well, this is the initiation
of the session.
You do a post.
Again, we'll see this is the
upload type of resumable, and
you just send the metadata.
We do ask you to add these
two extra headers, the
X-Upload-Content-Type and the
X-Upload-Content-Length, that
specify the size and the content
type of the file you
are going to be sending in the
remainder of the session.
This time, you'll get
a 200 response back.
And remember I said you'll get
the URI to send the rest of
the data to.
There it is.
It's the session URL,
and it comes back
in a location header.
So you should pass this header
and see where to send it to.
Then you perform a PUT to
that URI containing
the rest of the data.
And that data should be the
correct content type.
You set a special Content-Range
header that
tells how much you're sending.
In the successful situation,
you'll get a 201 response
back, and that's all
you need to do.
In the situation of failure,
remember I said you can query
the API to find out how much
you've already uploaded.
Well, here's how.
You send it a PUT request which
is an empty body, but
has this header Content-Range
that is just slash.
That means how much
have I uploaded?
And we'll return the 308
response back with a range of
how many bytes.
So we can see that when we
restart this upload, we start
from the 524,288th byte, and we
continue to send the rest
of the data.
So really good.
These days a lot of applications
are on mobile
platforms, and, really,
people have to
pay for this bandwidth.
So we'll talk about these
efficiency measures later.
But really, just remember,
this is one of those ways
where you can save bandwidth.
You can save uploading
the same file twice.
Of course, as I said, you can
just use our client libraries.
And this is the Java example
of how to perform that.
So I won't walk through it,
because it's simple Java.
But you can see it's just a few
lines, and that makes it
very, very easy.
Resumable upload is the default
mechanism for the Java
library, so without knowing it,
you would use this, the
best method.
So that's how to get your
files up into Drive--
jalapeno drive.
And to get them out and to
show you all the other
beautiful features of the
API, I'm going to
hand over to Ivan.
IVAN LEE: Great.
Thanks, Ali.
Hey, everyone, I'm Ivan Lee.
I'm a member of the Drive
SDK team here at Google.
And now that Ali showed us how
to get all these files into
your drive, I'd like to show
you some of the compelling
operations that you can perform
on these drives.
So for example here, obviously,
you're going to
probably want to get your photos
back out of your photo
album, so you're going to want
to be able to download it.
In that case, all you have to
do is take the download URL
that's available in the metadata
four file, and
perform a GET on that
download URL.
So you perform the GET, provide
the authorization
headers just as you did with all
the other requests so that
we know what scope you have, and
you'll get the binary data
just as you'd expect.
Just as Ali had talked about
performing a resumable upload,
we do honor the Content-Range
headers.
So that if you want to
effectively perform a
resumable download, you
can just specify those
bytes that you want.
This is great in terms
of if you'd like to
chunk up the download.
So if you're on a spotty
connection, and you want to
resume from where you were
before, or if you want to
actually download different
parts of the file in parallel
at the same time and reassemble
them on your side.
So here, for example, we specify
the Content-Range
header from the 512 kilobytes
to 1 megabyte range, and
you'll just get that
chunk back.
Those bytes in the
Content-Range header are inclusive.
We also give our users the
ability to restrict download
for a file.
So what this will do is it'll
allow the user to control who
can download this file.
So anybody that is a reader for
a file and they don't have
write or owner permissions,
they won't be
able to download it.
So in this response here, you
can see that the file has been
marked as restricted, and
whoever made this request does
not have edit permissions.
In this case, the download URL
does not show up, and they
can't perform a download.
Even if they did have a download
URL from before, and
maybe the user has marked it as
restricted since then, the
download URL will
stop working.
So we also talked about
converting a file into a
Google document.
So this will give you all
that collaborative
goodness that we provide.
And in order to actually get
that file back out of Drive,
we need to export it.
The original binary
file has changed.
So we have all these various
forms of exporting a file.
So for example here, a Google
document can be exported into
an HTML file or a PDF, and
there's four or five other
formats that we support.
In which case, you just need to
select the MIME type that
you would like to export to
and take the link that's
associated with that
MIME type.
Perform a GET on it using the
authorization headers as you
did with the download, and
you'll just get the binary
data as you'd expect.
Now, this really closes the loop
in terms of uploading a
file, converting it into a
Google Document, and being
able to collaborate, share,
view, all that good stuff, and
then be able to export it into
a more common format that
maybe some other applications
might be more familiar with.
Not only are these desktop
applications, but these can
actually be cloud
applications.
So if you had seen one of the
talks before, we had mentioned
how you can actually perform an
open with a Google document
in the drive, and your app
will actually be able to
perform an operation on that
file, since you will actually
export it as a read-only
snapshot.
So for example, if HelloFax
wanted to fax a file, it would
just have to say, open this
document as a PDF.
And it would just be able to use
that PDF as if it were a
regular binary file.
So now you have been able to
download your file, and maybe
you want to make some
touch-ups to it.
Maybe you want to do some red
eye reduction, or put
moustaches on everybody, then
you can do that with your app.
But now we have to get it back
into your drive so that
everybody else can see
those changes.
You actually have two options
when you do this.
You can actually completely
replace the file, or you can
actually update it, but create
a revision at the same time.
By creating a revision, you
actually get to see the
history of all the changes
you've made along the way, and
users will probably appreciate
being able to take those
snapshots as you add
those revisions.
So to choose the behavior that
you'd like to exhibit, all you
have to do is specify this new
revision query parameter.
So in this case, we've said,
newRevision=true.
And when you update it,
you'll get a new
revision for that file.
You'll be able to list those
revisions in the actual web UI
that we have.
And not only that, but we have
a revisions collection, so
you'll be able to perform
that listing.
You'll be able to delete,
update, download specific
revisions, and be able to
get all that history.
If you saw one of the other
talks, we really encouraged
auto-saving files
for your users.
The majority of users expect
cloud apps nowadays to perform
the auto-saving, and it almost
feels antiquated to have to
actually perform a save.
Now when you do this, if you
create a new revision every
time, that's great.
That provides a lot of
flexibility to your users,
lets them undo operations,
and maybe roll back.
However, this can get expensive
in terms of storage.
So from time to time, we
actually perform a little bit
of a clean up.
We delete older revisions, or
maybe if there's a certain
file that has had an excessive
number of revisions, we'll
start cleaning up those earlier
ones and leave the
more recent ones.
If you're uploading a revision
that you know it's important--
maybe it's a milestone, or the
user said, hey, really, really
hold on to this revision--
you can actually mark
it as pinned.
This way, it won't actually be
subject to that automatic
clean up, and it'll always be
available for your users.
They'll still have the same
properties in terms of being
able to delete, and update, and
download those revisions.
Do note that pinning a revision
will actually count
against your user's quota,
just because we can
never delete it.
So do be wary of that.
Make sure that it is a valuable
thing that you would
like to provide for
your users.
So let's say you want to
make a copy of a photo.
And you want to run a red
filter, and then a blue
filter, and a green filter, and
have these various copies.
Well, with our new move to this
new API architecture,
we're actually able to provide
you with custom endpoints.
So we can take a lot of the
pain points away from the
developer and perform them
on the server side.
This was a common complaint that
we had with our previous
API, was being able
to perform a copy,
especially for binary files.
So what we've done here is we've
actually provided you
with a copy endpoint.
So you can copy a binary file,
specify the metadata-- in this
case, we specified that the
title is "Fancier Photo."
And you can specify all the
other metadata that you would
on a normal upload.
In that case, it will actually
take that binary file, create
a copy of it.
You don't have to download
and re-upload.
You don't have to waste all that
bandwidth not only for
us, but for you and
your users.
You might be curious, OK, I
can specify the metadata.
Can I also specify some
query parameters?
And of course, yes.
So just as you were able to
say, convert this into a
Google document, or perform OCR,
or perform a translation,
you can do that exact same
thing on a copy.
It's just like an upload.
And it really lets you take away
a lot of the processing
power that you would normally
have to do in your server or
your application.
And we can do it on our
server since we
already have the bytes.
So maybe there are some photos
that went into your album that
shouldn't quite make
the final cut.
In which case, we actually
provide a couple different
ways to remove that photo.
The safer operation is
to perform a trash.
So what this will do is actually
move the file into
the user's trash.
It'll be fully recoverable.
All they have to do
is un-trash it.
This is great because it
actually delegates the
responsibility for permanently
deleting a user's file to the
actual users.
So they have a little more
ownership of it.
And the only difference that
shows up here is in the
metadata for the file that comes
back, it will be that
this trashed bit
is set to true.
However, there are situations
where you might want to
actually delete the file.
You don't want it to
go in the trash.
So for example, if your
application maybe creates some
temporary files to keep track of
how far it is along a whole
bunch of processing.
In that case, that would be a
great situation where you
wouldn't want to have to pollute
your user's trash with
a whole bunch of files that
they never even created or
even know what they are.
So in that case, we just have
this delete endpoint on the
file itself, just the regular
HTTP DELETE method.
And that'll just skip the trash
as you would expect.
Now that we have files in your
drive, you've cleaned up all
the old ones that you don't want
anymore, you'd like to
organize them.
Maybe organize them by
event, or by date,
or by friend groups.
Or even all three, since we
support multi-inclusion.
In that case, we just have the
children's collection in which
case you perform operations on
the actual folder itself.
And in the body, you just
specify various IDs for the
files that you would like
to put in that folder.
Conversely, we also have
a parent's collection.
So if you'd like to add a parent
to a certain file, then
you can do that multiple times
and just always be working on
that individual file.
Since we'd like you to make
as few requests as
possible, just because--
for both sides, we would
like to do that.
In that case, we allow you to
specify the IDs of the parents
in the actual metadata when you
upload a file, as Ali had
described before.
The great thing about this is
you can specify multiple
parents here, which was another
common pain point with
our previous API.
So here, if you specify 10
folders, normally, before,
you'd have to actually perform
10 different requests.
Here you can just perform one
request, and we'll add them to
all the folders for you.
So now that these photos are
just sitting in your drive,
they're pretty boring there.
I mean, one of the greatest
features of Google Drive is
the ability to share.
And not only just share
with one or two users.
There's various different types
of audiences that you
can share with.
So for example, if I had this
picture of me working hard on
the beach in Australia, and I
want to show it off to Ali
who's apparently stuck on an
escalator, I can just share it
directly with him as a user.
If I'd like to share it with
this group of people that
dress up as silhouettes, I can
share it with the group.
If I want to show off to my
coworkers and say, hey, I'm
not really working, but you guys
are, then I could share
it with the domain.
Or if I just want to completely
make it public,
since this is such a gorgeous
photo, then I can
just set it to anyone.
Now to actually add this
permission, all you have to do
is specify a few different
pieces of data.
So here you can specify the
type, just as I had discussed
in the last slide.
The role is the familiar role
that you see in our UI, either
reader, writer, or owner.
And reader isn't able to
actually edit the file.
Writer can edit the file,
and owner can
actually delete the file.
You might want to specify owner
in a case where you'd
like to transfer ownership.
So for example, maybe somebody
is retiring from the company,
and you would like to transfer
their documents from them to
somebody else that's in the
company, so you don't lose
that information.
That'd be a valid case
where you'd like
to specify an owner.
And for value, you just specify
either the email
address for the user of the
group or the domain, such as
google.com in the example
I showed before.
The main thing that I wanted to
highlight on this slide was
that the ID you get
back is actually
a key that we generate.
A big thing that we want to
address was we wanted to
provide better privacy
for our users.
So just because somebody's
shared something with me
doesn't mean everybody else that
is on the permissions for
that file should be able to know
what my email address is.
We really wanted to support
a better privacy
model for our users.
So the key that you get back
will just be a generated key.
You use that to perform various
operations with that
permission from now on.
We realize that it might be
convenient to be able to use
the email address just because
maybe it's just a little more
human readable.
We provide some convenience
methods, such as being able to
specify the current user,
exposing what this generated
key would be for a user in our
about collection, and so on.
So I guess a couple
years ago--
well, more than that-- a couple
guys started a search
company, and that
became Google.
And we thought that it would
be very valuable to include
Search with our API.
So to perform search, all you
need to do is specify the
query parameter, q.
And we have a special query
language here, such as being
able to search for any file
where the title contains
"birthday."
Notice that the string
is in single quotes.
And this isn't the only
query that we support.
So for example, you can search
for exact title queries.
So anything that exactly matches
"Anniversary 2012."
You can search for various
labels, so for example,
starred or trashed.
You can search for time
ranges, modified time.
We also support last
viewed time.
Full text is probably one of the
most powerful values that
you can search on.
Because that not only brings
in the title and the
description, it actually uses
that indexable text that we
had seen before in the example
where Ali had uploaded that
photo from the Three Sisters.
We also provide searching by
various levels of permission.
So if I knew that John Smith
was shared as a writer on a
file, then I can perform that
search just like that.
We also support owners
and readers.
And also being able to
search by MIME type.
Maybe your application only
works on a certain type of
MIME type, and that's the only
one that you care about.
Then you can just, in this
case, search for PDFs.
And also keep in mind that this
list continues to grow.
We always try to support
more and more fields.
So we actually have an entire
page on our documentation that
talks about searching.
So I highly recommend checking
back there from time to time
in case we do start supporting
other fields.
So finally, a very common use
case is that people want to
see what's been going on.
What kind of activity
do I have?
In our example, the
photo album.
So maybe has somebody uploaded
something new to the shared
folder that we've created?
Or has somebody started editing
some of these photos?
Since this is such a common use
case, we'd kind of like to
step through probably the best
practice in terms of syncing
these changes to a photo album
or whatever you're monitoring.
So in this case, all you see
here is we have four files.
They each have a change ID
associated with them.
We haven't synced
anything yet.
Maybe the user's just installed
your application, in
which case we haven't
synced anything.
Keep in mind here that nine is
our largest change ID, and
we're just about to
start syncing.
So now we actually sync those
files, perform maybe a list on
the files collection.
You can use a query in case
you're only interested in a
certain subset of those files.
Once you do that, you'll be
waiting for any changes that
might be happening.
You'll probably be polling every
couple minutes or so.
In the meantime, maybe
somebody's been updating your
files or deleting some of these
photos, in which case
these changes will start
to accumulate.
Now the next time you want to
see what's changed since the
last time you checked, all you
have to do is start from
change ID 10.
And you'll see everything that's
changed since then,
rather than having to sync the
entire drive over and over,
and perform the diffs
yourself.
So how does this look
with our API?
Well, we have this about
collection, which provides a
whole bunch of different
information to
you about the user.
So for example, there's quota
information, display name,
profile, URL, but what we're
concerned with here is the
largest change ID, in which
case the largest
change ID is 9.
We store that somewhere just to
keep track of where we are
in a snapshot in time.
We go ahead and sync the files
using the files collection
just as we talked
about before.
And now when we want to see, OK,
what's changed since the
last time I took a snapshot, all
we have to do is hit the
changes collection and specify
the start Change ID to be 10.
You'll notice in the
response that each
change has an ID number.
So in this case, the
first one is 10.
And this will be a monotonically
increasing
number, so you can keep track
of the changes as they go.
We also specify the file
ID that the change
is associated with.
So if you create a new file,
update it, delete it, that's
what that file ID points to.
Now there's also this
deleted flag.
So if you were to have deleted
this file, that's what that
flag tells you.
In this case, we see that
deleted is false.
So this is maybe just either a
create or an update in which
case we specify the file
metadata just as you would
expect if you were to hit
the files collection.
This saves you a round trip, so
you don't have to get the
file ID, and then just turn
right back around,
and ask us for it.
However, if the deleted was
true, that means that the file
has been completely deleted
from the user's drive, not
just moved to the trash.
In which case, we don't have
any information about that
metadata, so we can't actually
provide you with that
information.
So that file field will
actually not be
there in the response.
So those are just a few of the
operations that you can do
with our API.
There's actually a few more
that we couldn't touch on
because of time.
But we thought it would be most
valuable if Ali talked
about some best practices
that you can use
when using our API.
So, Ali?
ALI AFSHAR: Thanks, Ivan.
So as Ivan said, that's not the
whole API, but bits of it.
And you can pick and choose
the parts that you want.
I just want to talk about a
couple of best practices--
we'll go into them
in some detail--
on how we would prefer
you use the API.
It's good for us, and
it's good for you.
But overall, it's good for
the user if you do these.
The first one is what to
do in case of failure
when you make calls.
Now, the main cause for that
will be you're making API
calls too quickly.
We have a few layers of denial
of service protection.
So we don't want you to
get stuck by this.
If you do make a request too
quickly, what we return to you
is a 403 response.
That just means rate
limits exceeded.
And what should you do
in that circumstance?
Well, you should do exponential
back off.
So you should wait for a second
and then try again.
And if you still get the 403
response again, you should
wait for two seconds, double the
interval, and try again.
Of course, we recommend you add
a little jitter to stop
you making bursts of requests
all at the same time.
That won't help anything.
So keep increasing the time, and
eventually you'll get to a
point where you've hit the nice
equilibrium, and you can
get your responses back.
If, of course, you're using this
and you're still hitting
an absolute quota ceiling,
that's when you need to get in
touch with us.
We're keen that developers, if
they're doing it in the right
way, have as much quota as they
need to perform their
application, obviously
within reason.
But we're keen for that.
So we'll check it out,
make sure you're
doing everything right.
And if you are hitting that
ceiling, then get back in
touch with us.
So that's what to do in
the case of retrying.
Exponential back off and it
really will help your
applications.
The other side of this-- and
we've touched upon it--
is making sure that you
treat the user's
bandwidth as sacred.
Really, I've said here
every byte is sacred.
Some of you may get
the reference.
But there are a few ways
that you can do this.
Just reduce the amount
of data you're using.
On a mobile platform, people
have to pay for this.
And really, you don't want to
be the cause of costing them
bandwidth and costing
them money.
So the first two, fields and
PATCH, are ways in which you
can reduce either the request
you're sending or the response
you're getting back.
fields is a query parameter that
you specify that tells
the API that you only want
a certain subset of
fields to be returned.
So you're only interested
in the title.
You don't care what the
description is, what the MIME
type is, what the links are,
any of those other things.
So you just ask for the title
field, and that's
all you'll get back.
So immediately you've returned a
quarter of the response or a
10th of the response that you
would have done before.
The converse of that is
the PATCH operation.
Now, when you do a PUT, when you
do an UPDATE, you can send
all the data.
But if you'd like to just
send the title, or--
a really useful case-- just
send one of those binary
labels that I've been
mentioning, you just want to
send the starred label, this
is how you can do that.
You send a PATCH request, and
that frees you up from sending
all the other data, and
only the field you
send will be updated.
So PATCH and fields.
Send what you need, receive
what you need.
Send no more.
Now the other two-- well,
resumable upload
we've spoken about.
Use resumable upload.
It helps in the case of failure,
but why does that
help your user's bandwidth?
Well, it ensures that
you never upload
the same byte twice.
Every byte is sacred.
Never upload the same
byte twice.
Start off exactly from where
you left off, and continue.
Fortunately, resumable upload
is the default upload
mechanism in most of
the libraries.
So you would just be using
that without knowing.
So that's really great.
And lastly, as Ivan's just
mentioned, the changes feed.
There's no need to get a whole
list of all the files,
download them all, see which
ones have changed, get the
metadata, see if the
title's changed.
We can return that
feed for you.
And as long as you poll that
sensibly, then that will save
you, again, making a whole
number of requests, save you
downloading files when you
just don't need to.
So those four simple
best practices to
save your user's bandwidth.
They will appreciate
you for it.
We will appreciate you for it
because they will be happy.
So those are our
best practices.
And I'd like to just focus
a bit on where we're
going with this API.
We started to tell you that
this API replaces the
Documents List API.
Well, of course, it's not
just a static thing.
We're always looking at
improving our APIs and
especially this one.
Here's a list of features that
we're looking to improve.
The first one is a way for your
application to store its
custom metadata against our
files in Google Drive.
That's a very, very
requested feature.
And it's pretty cool.
Imagine if you have your own
ID for the file in your
database, you just store
it in Google Drive.
And then you can access
and get that later.
So you can just tag any
arbitrary data you want on to
your file, and that will
be really useful.
Batching, that's something the
Documents List API has.
You put a number of requests
together in a single request,
you send that to the API.
The Drive API will be
responsible for splitting each
of those requests up into their
individual operations,
performing each of those
operations, and then
aggregating the results, and
sending them back to you.
If you had to make 100 requests,
all very similar,
you could just send them as a
single batch request, and that
will save a huge amount
of network for you.
When you upload media files
to Google Drive, we know a
certain amount about them.
Obviously, images have Exif
data, movies have other kind
of data, transcoding
and subtitles,
these kind of things.
And we do all of that.
So we're trying to get
better at exposing
these things for you.
That would really help our
photo album application.
Because you'd have all the Exif
data, and you wouldn't
have to do any of that
processing yourself.
Really useful.
The other two features I've got
there, the first one is
push notifications.
Now, we've recommended you
use the changes feed.
Of course, that's great.
But why poll in a situation
where you're going to get a
push notification?
Obviously, this will
be different
for different platforms.
But every time a change happens,
we will send a
notification to your
application, whether it be a
web server, whether it be a
mobile device, whether it be a
client application
on a desktop.
They use different mechanisms,
but there will be a way that
we can send a notification to
your application to say
something's changed.
So no longer will you have to
be doing repeated polling.
Again, this will save a
huge amount of data.
And finally is our collaboration
engine.
One of my favorite features
about Google Docs and Google
Drive is that more than
one person can use the
file at the same time.
I mean, it's incredible.
You've seen it, you've
used it.
5 people, 10 people can use
it at the same time.
You see all the cursors, you see
what everyone's writing at
the same time.
This will no longer be limited
to our applications.
This is a JavaScript library
that you will be able to put
in your applications to
provide this amazing
collaborative functionality.
We had a talk on this by Josh
and John called "Launching the
New Google Drive SDK,"
and they actually
have a demo of this.
And if you can check that video
out on YouTube, it's
pretty cool, we think.
So those are our future
features.
These are in the immediate
future.
You know we're busy.
But the important thing here is
that we are guided by you.
So we want to know what features
you want in the API,
and we will implement them.
You're thinking, wow,
what a nice guy.
It's not because
I'm a nice guy.
The people we care about most
are the users of Google Drive.
Your applications enhance their
experience, improve
their experience.
Your excellent applications
enhance their
experience a lot.
And so if you can make them
happy, if you can improve
their experience in Google
Drive, then that makes us
extremely happy.
Makes everyone happy.
So that's why we love you.
That's why we love developers.
And that's why we really
care what you think.
So star those issues.
Send me an email telling me we
have to have this feature, we
have to have this feature.
Send us an email saying,
wow, you're so great.
But really, get in
touch with us.
Tell us what you need, and
we will be guided by you.
Happy user, happy developer,
happy Google.
Thank you very much
for listening.